vamos a hablar un poco sobre lo que
significa comprar acciones en una
compañía vamos a escribirlo incluso y
creo que todos tenemos una noción un
poco básica de lo que son las acciones
sin embargo en este vídeo lo que
buscaremos es tener realmente el
concepto de qué es lo que estamos
comprando cuando compramos acciones de
una compañía y lo que realmente esto es
acciones cuando tú compras acciones
básicamente lo que sucede es que te
vuelves parte dueño de esta compañía te
estás volviendo parte dueño
una compañía
esto es cuando compras acciones y
simplemente para contrastarlo con los
bonos voy a escribir también lo que son
los bonos
vos
y esto lo haré netamente para compararlo
o contrastar lo como les decía ya que
muchas veces se utiliza el mismo término
entre los inversionistas así como hoy
sabes estoy comprando acciones o hoy
estoy comprando bonos los bonos lo que
nos hacen es parte prestadores a esta
compañía y a lo que me refiero comparte
es que esta compañía lo que está
pidiendo es un préstamo y nosotros lo
que estamos haciendo es aportar una
parte de ese préstamo así que seremos
parte de prestadores a la empresa vamos
a colocarlo parte
calor
a la compañía
y por ejemplo si tú estás comprando un
bono lo que estás haciendo digamos que
este bono tiene un valor de 1000 dólares
y hay mil personas que estarán comprando
bonos para esta compañía esta compañía
lo que están haciendo es recibir un
millón de dólares en préstamos y
nosotros tendremos un bono por mil
dólares vaya no voy a entrar en mucho en
estos detalles de los bonos en este
vídeo porque realmente lo que vamos a
analizar son las acciones simplemente es
para que tengan una idea aquí ustedes
son parte dueños de la compañía y aquí
simplemente están prestándole dinero o
una parte de ese dinero a la compañía
así que para hacer esto un poquito más
tangible déjenme escribirles es
exactamente una hoja de balance de una
compañía equis y con esto podremos
entender bien las acciones vamos a hacer
un dibujo y pondré aquí compañía
compañía x digamos que con esta compañía
x vamos a ver todos los activos pasivos
y capital qué significa esto lo
detallaremos poco a poco pero lo primero
que haremos son los activos los activos
de esta compañía x digamos que son estos
y cuando hablamos de activos sobre lo
que realmente nos estamos refiriendo es
en el día a día todo aquello o todas
aquellas cosas que tienen valor cosas
que en un futuro nos darán un beneficio
por ejemplo una casa no representa un
activo ya que nos da la posibilidad de
vivir y cubrirnos del sol y de la lluvia
y del frío una auto es un activo y
pertenece también aquí a los activos
porque nos da la posibilidad de movernos
de transportarnos otro tipo de activos
por ejemplo es el efectivo este efectivo
lo podremos intercambiar por algunos
otros bienes si nosotros le hacemos un
préstamo
alguien también será un activo y esto
porque el dinero ahorita no lo tendremos
sin embargo en un futuro pues nos dará
un beneficio y nos lo pagarán
sin embargo cuidado un préstamo que nos
hacen va a ser una deuda y eso lo
tomaremos en los pasivos que más
adelante hablaremos bueno ya que tenemos
claro que es un activo vamos a decir que
el activo de esta compañía vale algo así
como 100 millones de dólares
en millones que entre todos los bienes
que les he mencionado tal vez las
patentes de los derechos de autor no se
el producto que vende en el edificio en
el que están no sé tenemos todos estos
activos que valen 100 millones de
dólares ahora digamos que también esta
compañía xd de dinero le ha pedido
dinero a alguien y entonces hablaremos
que tiene ciertas deudas
y esto que le debe al mundo se llaman
los pasivos
los pasivos al contrario que los activos
es todo aquello que le debemos a alguien
más puede ser un préstamo puede ser
bonos como les había dicho aquí puede
ser que le debamos dinero a los
proveedores a la gente que nos da el
producto que vamos a vender oa
diferentes tipos de deuda ahorita no
vamos a entrar en detalles simplemente
digamos que todo lo que ha pedido
prestado a un solo banco oa diferentes
personas tiene un valor de 80 millones
de dólares y como les decía puede ser
para una sola persona o sea puede ser un
préstamo hecho por un solo banco o lo
podemos tener por bonos esencialmente
tenemos 80 millones como deuda
y entonces aquí ustedes pudieran ser
parte de los bonos solo para recordarles
lo que significan los bonos que nos
deberían dinero a nosotros todo esto lo
llamamos pasivos olvide poner aquí que
esto es deuda
duda también podemos pensar que hay
otros tipos de pasivos que no sean deuda
pero por cuestiones de simplicidad por
el momento solo vamos a considerar los
pasivos como la deuda que tenemos ahora
hablemos de qué es lo que le queda a los
dueños y una buena manera de pensar
sobre qué es lo que van a tener los
dueños es que si nosotros consideramos
que esta empresa realmente tiene activos
lo suficientemente fuertes como para ser
vendida en 100 millones pues digamos que
vendemos la empresa recibimos 100
millones por ella y lo primero que
haremos es pagar la deuda están de
acuerdo
si nosotros pagamos la deuda de esos 100
millones que teníamos como activos
prestaremos 80 millones y nos quedará un
capital
de 20 millones de dólares
este es el capital como muchas veces lo
han escuchado en las hipotecas y aquí
tendremos 20 millones de dólares que
será realmente el capital o lo que queda
para los dueños
les mencionaba que esto es similar a una
hipoteca si nosotros tenemos una casa de
300 millones
y todavía me queda pagar 200 millones
significa que solo he pagado 100
millones ese sería el capital que ya he
pagado dicho es muy sencillo lo que
estamos viendo aquí y se los voy a
escribir van a tener su primer clase
introductoria de contabilidad
podemos decir que los activos son igual
a los pasivos
más el capital están de acuerdo activos
son igual al pasivo más el capital o si
restamos en ambos lados los pasivos
tendríamos que los activos
- los pasivos
serán igual al capital
vamos a poner el capital serán iguales
al capital y esto puede tener un sentido
mucho más lógico porque lo que
tendríamos como dueños es exactamente el
total de los activos menos el pago de
las deudas y simplemente nosotros nos
quedaríamos con lo que queda digamos
entonces que yo soy dueño de acciones en
esta compañía x entonces un pedacito de
aquí sería mío por eso decimos que somos
partes dueños de la compañía somos
partes dueños del capital nosotros
compramos acciones así es que por
ejemplo si nosotros tenemos 2 millones
de acciones vamos a escribirlos aquí
tenemos 2 millones de acciones
y nuestro capital tiene un valor total
de 20 millones lo que haremos para saber
el valor de cada una de estas acciones
pues será dividir los 20 millones de
capital
millones de capital
20 millones de dólares de capital
entre los dos millones de acciones vamos
a colocar aquí dos millones de acciones
si hacemos esta división lo que
tendremos es que cada una de estas
acciones tendrá un valor de 10 dólares
de capital por cada una de las acciones
si creemos que todos estos números son
correctos y sabemos que esta compañía
tiene 2 millones entonces podemos decir
que esos 10 dólares por cada acción
realmente son un valor aceptable y si
alguien está dispuesto a vendernos
alguna acción en algún precio menor a 10
dólares pues tal vez sería un buen
negocio comprarlos sin embargo si
alguien estuviera dispuesto a pagar más
de 10 dólares pues a nosotros nos
convendría vender nuestras acciones y
tendríamos una ganancia y sonaría un
buen negocio sabes para que vean cómo
funciona todo esto y que no lo estoy
inventando vamos a tomar los datos de
una compañía en un momento más les
enseño estos datos y lo que haremos es
este mismo diagrama o este mismo balance
hacerlo con los datos que tenemos y ver
si realmente funcionan como les estoy
diciendo
tengo estos datos de una compañía
digamos que es secreta si ustedes
descubren cuál es la compañía se llevan
puntos extras ok tenemos estos datos y
haremos exactamente el mismo balance
donde teníamos activos pasivos y el
capital de acuerdo a sus reportes
financieros estos son sus reportes
financieros y los tomaremos para saber
los valores de la acción justo como lo
acabamos de hacer bueno ya que tenemos
toda la información vamos a empezar con
los activos recuerden que nuestros
activos
son todo aquello que tiene un valor y
que podremos
e intercambiarlos o que nos darán un
beneficio dentro de sus reportes tenemos
aquí activos vamos a tener cerca de 30
millones estoy tomando la información
más reciente bueno de hecho home tenemos
2009 y 2008 simplemente es la
comparativa entre ambos pero nosotros
tomaremos el más reciente aunque sea
información ya bastante viejita
decíamos entonces que el total de los
activos que nosotros tenemos suman
cerca de 30 millones vamos a redondear
los a 30 millones 30 millones de activos
dejaré marcado con el mismo color de los
activos
el dato que estamos tomando lo que sólo
para que tengamos mayor claridad y tal
vez sientan un poco de curiosidad para
saber de dónde salen estos 30 millones
totales de activo
tenemos el activo corriente que es todo
aquello que se va a convertir en
efectivo digamos que en menos de un año
normalmente bueno es el efectivo o las
cuentas que vamos a cobrar dentro de un
año los inventarios que son todo el
producto que tenemos y que estaremos
vendiendo a corto plazo y otros activos
corrientes que también se convertirán en
efectivo durante el próximo año sin
embargo tenemos otra clase de activos
que son más a largo plazo que no los
convertiremos en efectivo en un año como
el edificio la planta toda la todo el
equipo o maquinaria que utilizamos y con
esto sumamos los 30 millones que estamos
considerando
activos ahora vámonos con todos los
pasivos los pasivos los tenemos de este
lado igual tenemos pasivos corrientes
que son todas aquellas deudas que hemos
de pagar durante el siguiente año
tenemos 16 millones 299 mil 152 estos
son a corto plazo pero también tenemos
deuda a largo plazo que son casi 5.5
millones si nosotros sumamos ambos
números tendremos alrededor de 22
millones los cuales colocaremos aquí
como pasivos
22 millones
en pasivos
que son todo aquel dinero que debemos o
que hemos de pagar al corto oa largo
plazo
entonces nos podemos preguntar bueno
pues cuánto queda para el capital
nosotros lo que haríamos o de acuerdo a
lo que vimos en nuestro balance antiguo
en nuestro balance pasado decíamos que
al activo le restamos los pasivos y
tendremos un total de capital de 8
millones 30 millones -22 millones nos
dará más o menos
8 millones y digo más o menos porque
recuerda que hemos redondeado estos
números estamos hablando de 8 millones
de capital que de hecho lo podemos ver
en nuestros resultados financieros aquí
capital ellos ya hicieron todas las
matemáticas correspondientes y han
llegado a 8.4 millones como capital
nosotros hemos redondeado y tenemos 8
millones dentro de nuestro balance sin
embargo este es el dato duro de acuerdo
a sus libros y nos referimos a sus
libros porque bayas son sus reportes
ellos los han escrito y confiamos que
esto es correcto 8.4 millones como
capital
ahora sí ya tenemos toda la información
y si realmente creemos que esta compañía
tiene activos con un valor de 30
millones y que todos estos números son
reales yo me preguntaría bueno cuánto
sería el valor de cada una de las
acciones de esta empresa y esta vez
haremos lo mismo que hicimos
anteriormente dividiremos los 8 millones
del capital
entre el total de acciones que tiene la
empresa que en este caso es de 2.78
vamos a hacer los números que tienen en
el libro dos puntos 78 millones de
acciones y entonces tendríamos aquí un
total de 8.4 millones están de acuerdo
vamos a reescribir los 8.4 millones de
dólares para que tengamos un número
mucho más cercano
8.4 millones de capital
que será dividido entre los 2.8 millones
de acciones
buscaré una calculadora y entonces
podremos hacer la división
haremos 8.4 millones de dólares como
capital entre dos puntos 78 millones de
acciones eso nos dará un total de 3
puntos 0 2 vamos a redondear lo a 3
dólares
tres dólares
de capital por cada axia
ok vamos a ver si esto es real esto
indicaría que de acuerdo a los libros o
de acuerdo a los números que tiene la
empresa cada una de estas acciones
valdría tres dólares en el mercado vamos
a ver si eso es real en el mundo y para
eso tenemos esta información que es la
información de las acciones por cómo se
comportan en el mercado nos está
diciendo que la última transacción
estuvo en dos dólares con 58 centavos
por acción esto significa que en el
mercado se está vendiendo por abajo del
precio que nosotros estamos calculando
la única situación que esto nos pudiera
suceder es
la persona que está vendiendo estas
acciones no crea que realmente la
empresa vale 30 millones de dólares por
eso están dispuestos a cobrar menos por
cada una de las acciones vamos a
analizar un poco toda esta información
para que vean realmente cómo se está
moviendo en el mercado entonces de
entrada se está vendiendo por abajo que
los tres dólares que ya hemos calculado
este dato de rango a 52 semanas nos
indica en las últimas 52 semanas o el
último año cuál ha sido el precio en el
que se ha vendido esta acción y va desde
un dólar con 20 centavos hasta 284 de
cualquier manera hemos tenido un buen
negocio sabes porque si en algún momento
compramos las acciones en 120 bueno hoy
se están vendiendo en 258 lo cual ya nos
hubiera representado una ganancia
tenemos también aquí el volumen promedio
de venta
diario son las acciones que se están
vendiendo diario y también tenemos esto
que es la compra la compra nos está
diciendo cuál es el número específico
que alguien ha dicho yo estoy dispuesto
a comprar una acción por en este caso
dos dólares con 46 centavos o venta nos
implica cuál ha sido el número que si se
ha dicho espín específicamente o se ha
hecho tangible en el que nosotros
estamos dispuestos a vender nuestras
acciones por 258 vamos a ver otro dato
que super interesante es el capital de
mercado y seguramente ya lo han
escuchado ustedes
en este capital de mercado lo que
realmente están diciendo es cuánto vale
para el mercado este número nosotros
teníamos de acuerdo a los libros que
tienen un valor de 8.4 millones de
dólares sin embargo vamos a ver que
realmente no es así tenemos aquí siete
puntos seis millones de dólares y como
ellos lo están calculando es al
multiplicar estos dos puntos 58 dólares
que se están calculando por cada una de
las acciones multiplicado por el número
total de acciones estamos de acuerdo por
dos puntos 78
si nosotros sacamos la calculadora
podemos hacer la multiplicación y
pondremos 2.58 dólares por acción
x 2.78 millones de acciones esto nos
dará 7.17 millones de dólares
qué bueno tal vez por cuestiones de
redondeos tenemos aquí la diferencia
pero se asemeja más a 7 millones que los
8.4 millones que nos están hablando en
los libros
bueno pues espero que este vídeo les
haya sido útil y les dé un poco de
sentido sobre lo que realmente significa
comparar acciones sobre una empresa